welcome to exploring computing
today's video is privacy
so i think the first thing we should
talk about is why is privacy different
in the digital age
what makes privacy uniquely interesting
in a networked digital world
so i think there's a number of changes
that have recently occurred
that uh heavily impact privacy
and so let's talk about some of these
there's a lot more information available
for tracking so
you know almost everybody has a cell
phone at this point and cell phones can
track our movement
there's the obvious which you know
as you as you move the cell phone around
as you drive around the city
uh your cell phone is contacting
different cell towers
and that can be used to track your
movements but
it actually turns out that you have much
finer grain
tracking than just the cell towers in
many situations
as your cell phone's moving around um
it is also contacting different wi-fi
networks
and different wi-fi routers as you move
about
an area and it turns out those can also
be used to track your movements
so just to provide an example nordstrom
says experiment with tracking
how customers move from one part of the
store to another
by watching where cell phones
try to connect the different networks as
they move around store
also closed circuit television cameras
are
all over the place now and they can also
be used to track where we go
the united kingdom is estimated to have
one closed circuit television for every
10 to 15 people
technologies like amazon's ring
doorbells with cameras also can be used
to track movement
particularly once you have a relatively
large number of these in an area
then you can sort of put together the
video coming from each of these
different doorknobs
in order to track movement and later on
we'll be talking about how
china is used in close circuit
television to attract people as well
also as we move our consumption of media
to digital devices
it makes it very simple to
track our media consumption habits so
you know
digital newspapers and magazines digital
books
digital tv shows and movies
as long as you are not using physical
medium you are instead using digital
medium
it's super simple to track everything
that you're viewing everything you're
reading
everything you're watching these can be
used
by the government to determine your
reliability and in fact
i will see an example a little bit later
on on how china
may be using this for their social
credit system uh
being used to determine the reliability
of their citizens and giving them
rewards or punishments on that basis
and i think the situation is liable to
get worse and not better
as we move to smart cars which have
some smart technology in them and then
we move to self-driving cars it's going
to be very easy to track your movements
smart homes can provide information to
whoever has access to them on your
activities and home
and in fact smart tvs which is
pretty much most televisions that you
would buy now that have some sort of a
i suppose i can call an operating system
i think many of them are based on
android
uh built into them which allows you to
uh select put different applications on
them and select different movies
and watch different movies some of these
companies are actually selling
information about your viewing habits so
in addition to
having all this information we now have
sufficient
processing power to really take
advantage of it
and this can also be combined with the
ability to store
a lot of information and then run
processing after the fact on it
that gives us the ability to strip away
things that were traditionally thought
of as private
so previously let's say we were
trying to track a particular vehicle
across the city maybe somebody had been
kidnapped
we had some sort of a hostage situation
the police could use the closed circuit
television cameras that are available in
some streets that are used to track
to look at traffic patterns and they
could say oh we're going to go ahead and
watch the uh watch the hostages uh
vehicle
travel across the city and so that's
something they could do live before
but what we're able to do now or what
we're
the direction we're moving in as storage
becomes cheaper and cheaper
is to store all the information from all
the traffic cameras
and start over a period of time so
the exact amount of time we would be
able to save it would depend upon our
storage capacity and how cheap storage
gets but you could certainly imagine a
situation where
you could store several days worth of
traffic or
you know at some point you may be able
to start months worth of traffic
and then process it later on so you know
maybe
there's nothing going on right now but
then you're like
hey so-so is uh you know i think
so-and-so is in a scandal let's go ahead
and uh
dig up the tapes from three months ago
um here's his license plate number
uh let's go ahead and see if we can
search all of
the data from all the traffic patterns
to see if we can find his license plate
number
and then see what he's been up to so you
know i think
the direction we're headed is
potentially worrisome from a privacy
standpoint
and this combination of storing massive
amounts of data
and then being able to process it
this is what sometimes referred to as
big data and it's something that's
available for both commercial
users and government users and it's
something that we may want to think
about like
do we want to regulate this what sort of
society do we want
and we'll talk about this a little bit
later on lecture when we talk about
both commercial issues with privacy and
then government issues with privacy
okay so um as far as u.s law goes
so it turns out that some of the
protections afforded by u.s law are
being eroded by our computing
capabilities
for example the supreme court has ruled
that individuals have the right to
practical obscurity
and so the way this played out or one
example of how this played out is that
requests for fbi rap sheets using the
freedom of information act were turned
down
on the basis of the need for practical
obscurity
and while that information was publicly
available the idea is that
somebody would have to go through and
gather all that publicly available
information and that was a time
consuming thing so
those listed had practical obscurity
because of the difficulty of tracking
down all the information but of course
now it's trivially easy to track down
information in fact
companies gather this information you
may have seen their advertisers on the
web like
hey do you want to look up what your
high school significant other was doing
look them up find out where they live
now find out what their income is
find out if they're married so the
practical obscurity is
uh largely gone because of computing
power
the european community is probably doing
the best job
of being active trying to protect the
privacy of their citizens
um there's been several things that
they've done one thing that they've done
is that in 2014 the european court of
justice
ruled that in certain circumstances its
citizens had the right to be forgotten
and under this ruling search engines had
to remove
certain search results so if a newspaper
had an article
that they had written previously they
were still allowed to leave that up on
their
website but search engines couldn't
directly link to those articles
within a half year of the court ruling
uh
on the right to be forgotten google had
received over 120
000 requests for deletion of information
another move that the european community
has made is
the european general data protection
regulation
and this uh was agreed upon in 2016 and
took place two years later
you will most notice this because of the
annoying
uh pop-ups that you're constantly
getting whenever you visit a website
saying are you okay star
information i mean it turns out that
california has also made similar moves
uh very recently so
you may be getting some additional
pop-ups because of california's new laws
so what does the general data protection
regulation actually do
well here are the key things that the
gdpr
requires um if a company is storing
somebody's information is breached
individuals must be notified within 72
hours of a breach
it's not unusual without this law it's
not unusual for a company to
not even tell people that their data is
out there or
to wait as long as possible despite the
fact that people knowing their data is
out there
might be an important thing for those
people to be able to protect themselves
gdpr requires all
individuals whose information has been
leaked to be notified in the 72 hours
individuals also have the right to
access the information that the
company's storing about them
they have the right to have data removed
about them
and companies are reminded that they
should have privacy
designed into their products from the
start in addition
uh companies that fit
into certain characteristics must have
data protection officers and those data
protection officers must report to the
highest levels of management
and they're responsible for making sure
that the data is properly protected
violations of the gdpr do have some
teeth
and they may require penalties as high
as four percent of a company's worldwide
revenues
all right let's take a look at a
commercial use of data
so one thing that privacy advocates
sometimes talk about
is this concept of you are either a
customer or a product
and so this is basically saying there's
no such thing as a free launch
if you are using a product and you are
not
paying for it and you are not getting
that
service from a non-profit or
perhaps the government then the company
that you are
getting that service from needs to be
making their money
somehow if you're paying for it well
great that's how they're making their
money
if you're not paying for it then
probably
they're making money by selling either
access to you or information about you
so um you know either directly
they're taking information about you and
selling it directly or
they are showing targeted advertising
for to you
and unfortunately it's now possible for
you to both be a customer
and also be a product so just as an
example
as of 2017 internet service providers
can now sell information
on your web browsing habits to others
even though you are actually
paying them for your internet service
so should we be concerned so you know
one thing to be thinking is hey
i use google or i use bing
or i use uh i i guess duckduckgo i can't
think of any other services offhand
as my search engine and obviously they
have to pay the bills so
um seeing targeted advertisements
because
um i'm able to use google for free that
seems like a reasonable thing
um but the thing to be concerned about
is where's the line and is that line
enforced by custom or is it enforced by
the law
and to give you sort of a classic
scenario that privacy advocates have
put out there um if i am
searching websites looking for things
about cancer perhaps i have a friend who
has cancer
or a parent has cancer or i have cancer
there's no way they know but is it okay
for the search engine to take the
information that i am searching
for cancer turn around and
sell that information to my insurance
provider
and for my insurance provider to jack up
my rates on the theory that
i might actually have cancer are we okay
with that
and how is it if if we're not okay with
that how is it going to be enforced
all right another thing that you should
be thinking about when you are
entering information that you think of
as private
onto a website or providing it to a
company
is you know both is this
something that it would be legal for
them to share with people
but also is it possible that someone
might illegally gain
access to this information so you know
in addition to thinking
do i think this company has good
intentions
you should also be thinking do i trust
this company has good enough security
that this information isn't going to
actually leak
that they're not going to get hacked in
spite of whatever good intentions they
might have
and so let's take a look at a couple
examples where
maybe people shouldn't have trusted
these companies with our information
all right so one of them is equifax
so equifax is a credit uh
agency it's one of those companies that
keeps track of
what we do with our financial in the
financial world
and with our credit cards and whether or
not we're credit worry
worthy um and so they got breached
and a lot of people had their names
their social security numbers
their birth dates and their addresses
stolen in this breach
and in addition some of them had their
driver's license numbers
stolen and it turns out that if you have
a social security number and a driver's
license
you create fake identities and create
credit card accounts for people so
that combination right there is super
dangerous um
and just to kick some extra sand on to
the people whose information was
breached
um someone created a fake help website
and there was a real website for help
called
equifaxsecurity2017.com somebody created
one called securityequifax2017.com
and it was close enough that equifax
accidentally
tweeted the wrong website out on their
twitter account
but the good news is in this case the
fake website was created by a security
expert to kind of
make a point the other thing that's a
little bit odd about the equifax breach
is
none of us are customers of equifax we
don't really agree for our information
to be up there
um i mean there might be something some
fine print in the credit card
credit cards we sign up for or maybe the
banks we work for that says they're able
to pass the information on equifax but
none of us are directly customers of
equifax and yet they had all this
information and that information was all
lost
okay here's another famous example
ashley madison
um if you're not familiar with ashley
madison that's probably a good thing
ashley madison was a dating website for
adulterers
and they got hacked and 9.7 gigabytes of
data was taken including members names
addresses phone numbers birth dates and
sexual preferences
um one thing that the new york times
pointed out was that
when uh this information was released
it was entirely possible for the hackers
to insert some fake data
into it um so yeah
anyway so people trusted ashley madison
with their information
they shouldn't have perhaps ashley
madison had good intentions
but they did not have good computer
security
all right so our next example is
facebook over 50 million profiles on
facebook were taken and sold to
cambridge analytica
users were falsely told by a cancer
professor that their data would only be
used for academic purposes
um but not only was the data
for those people who thought it was only
going to be used for academic purposes
taken
but it also turns out that the
professor involved was able to access
information on their friends as well and
so
this is a little bit different than the
previous examples because
it wasn't that the company got hacked
but it was rather that they were working
with somebody and that somebody
violated the terms of agreement and did
something that was dishonest
but uh you know nevertheless the people
involved had their information taken
and stolen and sold to a third party
facebook was not technically hacked but
people sort of fell for what turned out
to be kind of a
sort of a scam where uh the person had
intentions to do something untrustworthy
you could argue that this is arguably a
case of social engineering
in addition facebook has had several
occasions where they've had to fire
employees because those employees were
cyber stalking people
taking advantage of their position at
facebook to cyber stock
so these are both reminders that if you
put information up there
even if the company has good intentions
not to share that information in ways
that
uh you know you you might not want it
shared
it is possible that bad things will
happen and the information will leak
anyway
all right our last example is the office
of personnel management
the office of personnel management acts
as a human resource department for
the federal government and among other
things it handles security clearances
and they got hacked information access
included personnel files
with names addresses birth dates and
social security numbers
probably more troublesome uh it included
background investigations for security
clearances which includes things like
you know have you done drugs are there
things that you know
you've done that that might lead to you
being blackmailed
so these are all the sorts of things
that might go into a background
investigation and it's going to be
stored on their computers which
got hacked good job guys in addition
digital images of fingerprints for
government employees were also stolen
now as to who did the hack it was
probably china
the tool used uh is associated with
chinese hackers
and in fact a chinese national has been
charged with work related to one of the
tools
used in the office of personnel
management hack here all right
let's move on to tools and techniques
related to
privacy so one technique that is used to
breach privacy is something called a web
beacon or a web bug
so these are used to track users on the
internet and
you guys can figure out how these work
because you know how html works and you
know how http works now so
essentially what a web bug or web beacon
is is it's a
one by one image
that appears on a web page it's
transparent so people don't actually
notice that it's there
and this is sometimes referred to as a
tracking pixel
and the idea here is this tracking pixel
has a unique id number
which identifies the specific individual
whose uh this web page has been served
up to and this can be used for several
different purposes
so one thing it can be used for is email
tracking so if you've got an invisible
image
on a html
mail file what happens is when somebody
opens up that
mail file the html file has that img src
equals it's got the name has a unique id
number
for this particular email and when the
server gets hit
by a request for that invisible tracking
pixel image it says oh the person with
that id number
just opened up the email message that's
why
i'm getting a request for that
particular tracking uh
tracking image um it can be used by
businesses to see if somebody's read a
particular email
um it can also be used by spammers to
see if that email address is active so
the spammers send out a bunch of emails
in html and all the emails are exactly
the same
except for the tracking beacon and so
there's going to be img
src equals and then there's going to be
a unique id number
dot jpeg or unique id number dot png
and now what's going to happen is when
you go ahead and receive that email
if your email is set up to display
images
your web browser is going to or your
email program is going to send an htc
request to wherever that tracking beacon
is coming from
and it's going to send a request for the
particular image file with that unique
id number that only you received in the
email message
and then the server on the other side is
going to see
that that specific id number was
requested
and it'll be able to match it up with
the original email
message that was sent and you may have
noticed that a lot of email programs
have an option to not display images
until
you specifically say oh i trust the
sender
go ahead and display the image now and
this is the main reason why they do that
to prevent
tracking of email
um these can also be used to track
people's movements across the internet
um
with third-party cookies and so when
we're talking about a third party what
we're talking about is
the first two parties are you and the
website that you're visiting so there's
a
that's party one and party two and party
three is some other party
um so the idea here is that a website
can allow a third party
such as an advertising network to track
a user's actions
across multiple websites and this can be
either done with these tracking pixels
that we were just talking about before
these
invisible one by one pixel images
or they might actually be done with the
visible advertisements
but what happens here is that when you
visit a web page
that is participating in this
third-party network with cookies what
will happen is
in addition to the regular contents of
that web page you will
also the html file will also reference
either that tracking pixel uh
web beacon image or it will
reference an actual advertisement that
shows up on the web page either way
it is requesting that web beacon
or that image file not from their
servers but from the third party servers
when you make that request from to the
third party servers what happens is
that third party sends that image
whether it's the tracking beacon or an
actual advertisement to you
and in addition it places a cookie
on your web browser so cookie store are
is a technique used to store small
amounts of information
in your web browser that can be uh set
back to the website the next time you
visit it so
like let's say you go to amazon uh
amazon's gonna put a little bit of
information
in your web browser such that the next
time you visit amazon
your web browser is going to send that
information back to amazon and that's
how amazon actually knows who you are
the next time you visit
similarly you know if you've got
subscriptions to things so like you know
i have a subscription new york times
the new york times keeps track of me uh
by putting this little cookie on my web
browser and the next time i visit the
new york times
my web browser sends that cookie back to
new york times when i visit and says oh
that's patrick
he has uh academic access to new york
times so
um he's fine um so the idea here is
these third-party networks because the
html files have references
to uh images from these
third-party servers the third-party
servers are able to send you
tracking information and put this cookie
information
into your web browser now when you move
to a different website
if that website is also serving up
images again whether they're
these invisible web beacons or their uh
visible advertisements
um when that request to that third party
that advertising
server comes up the third party cookie
that they had put in previously
is also going to get sent to them so
they'll be like oh this is the same user
i saw this user on this other website
i'm now seeing them in this website
and they can build up a picture of all
the different sorts of websites that you
visit
as long as you're visiting different
websites on that tracking network they
will be able to build up all the
information about
all what your web browsing habits are
and form a profile for you
now depending on what they want to do um
if you were to actually enter
information into one of these network
websites like let's say
you know these advertisements were
showing up
on a store web page or maybe the store
was working in conjunction with the
advertising
network even though the store wasn't
actually displaying images
and i enter in my name and phone number
and other information
that information can be used
in conjunction with the advertising
network if that website chooses to pass
that information on to the advertising
network
the advertising network not only has an
idea of what my web browsing habits are
but potentially they could have my name
address and phone number
and whatever other information i entered
into uh
the main website that was working in
conjunction with the tracking website
all right so this doesn't sound very
good
what can we do to protect our privacy
well
last lecture we talked a little about
about vpns virtual private networks and
how
um they do provide some privacy if you
want to go
further there's something called tor tor
is a special routing system that's
designed to let users remain anonymous
on the internet
you can kind of think of it like a super
powered vpn
with more protection but
it's much slower tor actually stands for
the onion router which refers the
multi-layered
nature of the network it uses when a
user accesses a torn
server their information is encrypted
and passes through a series of
tor servers and there are over 6 000
servers in the network
and so when you go ahead and access
something through tor what's going to
happen is
you are going to get a special sequence
through the tor network where your
information is going to get passed from
one tors server to another tor server to
another to our server
and when the information comes back it
should follow the same route
that information that routing
information is only good for 10 minutes
and if you make another access after 10
minutes you're going to get a different
sequence of random servers
the intermediate tor servers cannot see
what the data is
but ultimately in order for you to
access the regular internet
um ultimately on the far end
that information is going to have to be
decrypted and
the destination for your request needs
to be discovered
and so the last tor server is going to
be able to
have some idea of the information that
you've set
and so if you want your information to
be completely hidden
from the tor server you need to use
encryption on top of just using tor so
you could use something like https
or secure email just be aware that
by using tor by itself um
you are not fully encrypting your data
all right let's talk about government
uses of data and
government concerns with privacy so
one thing that i've often joked about in
class is that
i really don't care if the nsa can read
my emails so
you know the basic idea here is i do
want to protect myself against random
hackers
but if the nsa wants to break into my
accounts
i am not claiming to have such good
security that the nsa is not going to be
able to break my stuff
and read the emails i'm sending to my
students so
just be aware of that on the emails i'm
sending to you and the emails you're
sending to me
all right so should we be concerned
about this should i be concerned about
the fact that the us government maybe
the nsa can actually break into my
accounts well here's some things to
think about
online and anonymity protects drug
traffickers and terrorist organizations
and also allows online harassment of
individuals often with no
recourse on their side on the other hand
anonymity also protects women's rights
gay rights
and human rights activists that operate
in countries where
they might face harassment or worse from
the government so
i think it's a double-edged sword like
on the one hand
privacy can be used for really bad
things and on the other hand
privacy can be used for really good
things
so it's not clear if there's a straight
answer on this question
but ultimately if you want to see what a
government can do
if it wants to completely track all of
its citizens
you can take a look at what's going on
in china so
there's a couple of different things
china is doing related to
privacy issues and leveraging
uh all the capabilities of modern
computing
so one of the things they're working on
is something called the chinese social
credit system
according to the washington post the
communist party hopes to build
a culture of sincerity in a harmonious
socialist society
where keeping trust is glorious the
ambition is to collect
every scrap of information available
online about chinese companies and
citizens
in a single place and then assign each
of them a score
based on their political commercial
social and legal
credit the atlantic describes the system
as
the system provides abundantly for
sticks as well as carrots
a subversive political meeting or
religious service for example
or frequent known haunts advice are due
under the table
business with an unregistered informal
enterprise and the idea is that the
network will know about it and respond
by curtailing one's privileges
the state wants its citizens to believe
that there's
little point in trying to evade
detection of such acts
according to the bbc eight chinese
companies
are experimenting with state-sponsored
social credit pilot programs
one of the programs social credit scores
is used by
and in spite of having taken chinese in
college fourth quarter i'm afraid i
can't
pronounce chinese so i'm gonna say bye
hey but that could be totally wrong
sorry guys uh chinese biggest
matchmaking service so the idea here is
they're using the social credit score
for matchmaking
uh and again quoting from the previous
washington post article
and there are links to all these
articles in the class notes
according to the washington post in one
program in sweden county citizens were
given ratings from a to d
citizens were classified into four
levels those with an
a grade qualified for government support
when starting a business
and preferential treatment when applying
to join the party
government or army or applying for a
promotion
people with a d grade were excluded from
official support or employment
so basically the chinese government is
taking all that information that we
started off this lecture with saying
hey because we're now in the digital
world it's super easy to track your
movements
it's super easy to see what sort of
books you're reading and what sort of
movies you're watching
they can tell who you're talking to the
chinese government is taking all that
information together
and deciding how good of a citizen they
think you are and how closely you are
at following telling the party line and
on that basis they're going to control
your access to different resources
or they're going to try and punish you
if you're stepping out of line
um another thing that they're are doing
is they're using close circuit
television cameras
the new york times reports that the
chinese government has used facial
recognition technology to track and
control uyghurs
a largely muslim minority so if you're
not familiar the uyghurs are the group
that
is literally being placed into camps
re-education
camps on the basis of their ethnicity
and their religious beliefs the system
looks
exclusively for uyghurs based on their
appearance and keeps records of their
comings and goings
for search and review in addition
the chinese government is exporting this
technology
to other governments which are
interested in also controlling their
population
so i find both of these rather
disturbing
the chinese government is also working
on spyware on
cell phones and so there was an
application
that um was being pushed by the chinese
government
and uh some researchers went in
and basically tried to study what this
application was actually doing and they
discovered that
the app included a back door giving an
external user full
super user access to the phone
super user is essentially the operating
system has different levels of
protection
allowing different users different
ability to access different things and
super user basically means the top level
of user the one that can do anything
they want
and this at level access allows them to
access the photos and videos
audio recordings on the phone access to
the user's contacts
and internet activities and in addition
it's able to retrieve information from
960 other applications including
shopping travel and messaging platforms
the app collects and sends detailed log
reports every day containing a wealth of
user data
and app activity and all members of the
communist party were directed to
download the app as well as
other companies and organizations were
also pushing their members to
download this app so bottom line
i think there is potentially a lot of
bad things that can happen
because of uh what's going on and how
we've moved to the digital world
and i think it behooves us all as
citizens to keep track of what's going
on
and to try and push our government
to limit what both the government itself
and what companies can do because
ultimately when you move to
see what a totalitarian government can
do with all this information
it's actually pretty scary